We we have yet another sort of Four Seasons Hotel
versus Four Seasons total landscaping moment from
the now former Trump administration. The Guardian
is reporting that an Italian restaurant owner was
sanctioned by Trump and put on a blacklist, and it
has made his life a complete and total nightmare.
This is just a mistaken identity case. Trump
sanctioned the wrong guy, Alesandro. But Sony
owns a restaurant in the northern Italian city of
Verona, a beautiful part of Italy, Alesandro. But
Sony was sanctioned by the Trump administration
crackdown on blacklisted Venezuelan crude oil.
The US Treasury also mistakenly blacklisted
Stereographic graphic Labbe, a graphic designed
company owned by another man, also named Alesandro
Betsen in Sardinia. And that business owner
that Alesandro Bertone confirmed that
his company was hit with sanctions.
They declined to comment further. So what is
this all about? In 2019, Trump's government
put in sanctions on Venezuela's state oil
company called Petroleos, the Venezuela PDVSA.
The attempt here was to try to get Maduro, Nicolas
Maduro to resign the president of Venezuela. And
on his last day in office, Trump sanctioned
a network of oil films, firms and individuals
connected to the Venezuelan oil company. But
Sony, who's the restaurant owner in Italy,
discovered his company's name, AMG, S.A.S. de
Alesandro. But Sony was on the blacklist when he
went to his bank in January, the day before Trump
left office, and he was told his accounts had been
blocked. He thought it was a joke, he said covid.
It's already really difficult for restaurant
owners. Now, I don't even have access to my money.
What the hell is going on now? He said he was able
to solve the problem by dealing directly with the
US government and said he managed to get a visa
until 2023 and it was resolved. He got no apology,
he got no explanation, but his name ultimately
was removed from the list multiple Alesandro. But
Zonies having their companies sanctioned by Trump
because of an error. Now, I believe this was
no accident. What I believe happened is that
Trump went to this Italian restaurant and he
was expecting unlimited breadsticks like you
get at Olive Garden. And the owner said,
sir, this is a real Italian restaurant,
unlimited breadsticks. Give me a break. Trump was
furious and he vowed revenge, which came. Now,
that's a joke. What I really think happened is, as
usual, with the Trump administration incompetence
in the execution of already bad ideas. That would
be how I would summarize what took place here.
It seems as though at least one of two Alesandro,
but Zonies was able to get this all taken care of.